what you had was just gangs of local
youths just scale and fences trying to
push in complete breakdown of any sort
of authority at the front here we've
brought Liverpool fan Daniel Nicholson
back to the stand to France to retrace
the night he'd rather forget but wants
to ensure isn't forgotten I just can't
believe they got it wrong
this is as I say it's a modern city in
Western Europe it's an international
City amazing infrastructure this is a
huge open space that should be able to
accommodate 60 70 80 000 fans into the
ground but they got it wrong on the
knife the combination of the French
authorities the French government and
most of all to play in UEFA
it's taken more than eight months since
the Champions League final for fans to
receive full Vindication from UEFA
their own review report shows how much
the actions and inaction of football
officials and local authorities nearly
caused a fatal Crush we should be trying
to work out how we can work together
moving forward to ensure that situations
like Paris never come about again
a Club statement from a Liverpool claims
recommendations to prevent
organizational failures from an initial
French Senate inquiry are yet to be
implemented
and the UEFA review team found
complacency around major event planning
next year the Olympics are in Paris
using the stand to France and the
international Olympic Committee told Sky
News it's been assured changes
recommended will be implemented at
stadiums before then at the men's Rugby
Union World Cup later this year
supporters are still waiting to hear a
French response to uefa's report and
guarantees they'll be better protected
in future this cannot happen again
also really is when the report came out
and if indicated us as fans and it
exonerated us of any involvement in the
absolute channels that happened in km
but it's now time for your way fat to
act upon those recommendations not just
for us but for all football fans
like Daniel never want to confront such
disarray and dangers again at a stadium
and be left preventing lines being lost
rather than just watching and
celebrating their team Rob Harris Sky
News Paris